I love that he's so happy he's waving at
me
meanwhile go to the end Michael Buble
and his wife Louie sauna received a
special appearance from their superhero
on their latest Instagram livestream on
Friday evening this is our superhero we
have two other superheroes but this boy
you know what he's a big inspiration for
us and it was a big inspiration it was a
big inspiration for us to do this with
you
the couple's oldest son Noah stole the
show during the live Q&A session marking
his first video appearance since beating
cancer the six-year-old even convinced
of that to perform a song on his toy
guitar singing the chorus to Shawn
Mendes and Camilla caballo senorita I
love you I had what do I say I love you
I love it when you called me senorita
okay well that was that I'm no that cute
and Michael continue to engage Noah in
the conversation telling fans what he
wants to be when he grows up and his
favorite things about Fridays you know
what he wants to be when he grows up not
an actor not a singer he wants to swim
with sharks kidding I've only we don't
know I don't get a cent me see what's
your favorite thing about Friday do you
see Porky Pig will say yes already don't
say okay you know you don't get candy I
mean Dena [ __ ] [ __ ] okay but again I
don't know you got to sleep in your bed
that's all he cares about him and his
brother wanna sleep in our bed and we
say that tonight maybe we watch a movie
popcorn you know what a nice movie to
watch us maybe like the Barbie movie for
a PR nightmare from Barbie no baby
graphic part should I think you like
Josie Park anyway so that's finding and
of course the singer concluded the video
with a positive send-off to all his fans
that's it I hope you guys are good I
hope you
guys are staying strong and you know
what we have good days and bad days you
know listen this family's gone through a
lot you know it goes it's gone and you
know what and we still go through a lot
so and I know that you do too but we
love you you love them no yeah which we
do we pray for him every night
yeah pray for you every night and we
hope that you're safe and we hope that
you're good and three more I mean okay
this time you don't know two shows many
friends that they were looking at non
his friends saying hello no okay
anyway the Buble family and the Lopilato
family from locate a moose from
Argentina and Canada and wherever we're
from we send our love to you